nutria are rodents that were first
brought to America to be farmed for
their thick fur now they're hunted for
their meat but to find them thorn has to
head downriver to the marshlands
fortunately for me I already have a boat
I'm just trying to make it actually
River worthy the problem is that it's
been over a year since I built this and
so this is like a resurrection there's
two really large holes that are gonna
need patching what I'd like to do is
make some pine pitch glue but I want to
do it in a large volume so I'm gonna
make a kiln where I can cook a lot of
pine hearts I think that'll work here we
go every single time I've gone onion
this year it's hit or miss really and I
know Delia is depending on this food so
this nutrient home is really a chance to
show Delia that I can get me when I say
that I'm gonna get it just have to let
this get really hot here comes some
as that resin heats up it becomes liquid
and it comes out and then it'll run down
into the ramp and then go into the cut
once I've got the pitch in my pitch pot
I can then stir in charcoal and that'll
make it stronger and I can make glue
the coracle or a bull boat it's a pretty
ancient design basically the idea is
that a person just makes a basket and
you put it hide right over it hopefully
pine pitch glue will make a waterproof
patch and I won't be taking on water
through all these holes the only time
I'm going to find out if it works is
when it gets put in the water so I just
have to see what happens